benvenuti i suoni the stories in questo
nuovo video vedremo assieme 6 trucchetti
per il rientro a scuola quindi sei lai
fax per il back to school sono truccati
supercar i divertenti e creativi e anche
quest'anno abbiamo l'agenda a me come
diario l'agenda super personalizzabile e
creativa siete pronti iniziamo subito
con il primo trucchetto questo primo
l'aifa che per personalizzare la vostra
agenda la nostra agenda è l'azienda me
ea 7 cover sticker personalizzabili
quindi potete cambiare la cover quando
volete e quante volte volete ho scelto
ora la pagina da personalizzare per fare
questo trucchetto vi servono degli
acquerelli un pastello a cera bianco è
un pennello in spagna con il fratello
azione a bianco scrivete quello che
volete oppure disegnato e quello che
volete nella pagina dell'azienda
poi prendete un pennello immergetelo
nell'acqua immergetelo poi nella
cialdina di acquerello a scegliete voi
colori che preferite io ho scelto un
rosso e potete creare una sfumatura come
vedete ho messo arancione e giallo ma
potete scegliere la sfumatura che
preferite
dopodiché immergetelo nell'acqua e
passatelo sopra la scritta con il
pastello a cera bianco come potete
vedere rivelerà la scritta creata con il
pastello a cera bianco e creerà un
bellissimo effetto arcobaleno il mio
sembra un po un effetto tramonto per i
colori che ho scelto
penso che questo struccato sia super
carino da realizzare non solo
nell'agenda ma anche dei quaderni o
bigliettini di auguri
secondo trucchetto
[Musica]
per questo secondo trucchetto andremo
nuovamente a decorare e personalizzare
la nostra agenda me mi servono tre
evidenziatori di tre colori diversi
oppure potete utilizzarne 2 prima di
iniziare il trucchetto però ho deciso di
cambiare la cover alla mia azienda a me
ecco qua o un verso questa cover adesiva
bellissima potete anche mischiare i vari
colori e mettere una ics diversa
rispetto alla cover come ho fatto io qua
secondo me si sta benissimo
prendete uno degli evidenziatori e
tenetelo fermo con la mano sinistra dopo
di che prendete l'altro colore di
evidenziatore appoggiate la punta a una
delle estremità della punta dell'altro
evidenziatore in questo caso sta
appoggiando un po di blu è un po di
arancione ma potete usare i colori che
preferite
ed ecco qua una volta che andrete a
disegnare o scrivere con quelle
evidenziatore uscirà un effetto
arcobaleno
potete anche inviare un messaggio ai
vostri compagni o creare una scritta
carina con questo effetto super
arcobaleno
[Musica]
terzo trucchetto vi capita di voler
disegnare un cerchio magari perché state
facendo qualche disegno o perché volete
decorare la vostra agenda ma non vi è
semmai un bel cerchio perfetto ma essere
un uovo qualcosa di molto storto
ebbene c'è un trucchetto per creare un
cerchio perfetto ecco qua i miei cerchi
tutti storti
prendete una graffetta potete utilizzare
una graffetta un po più grande un po più
piccolo in base alle dimensioni del
cerchio che volete di segnare io questo
utilizzando una graffetta un po più
grande e mettete la penna al centro
della graffetta per tenerla ferma e poi
disegnate con l'altra penna o pennarello
ecco qua anche con la graffetta piccola
s il serchio
potete ora colorarlo decorarlo come
volete
[Musica]
quarto trucchetto vi capita che a scuola
si ha leggendo qualche compagno all
insegnante poi per un momento vi
distraete tornate a guardare al libro
ma vi rendete conto che avete perso il
segno e non riuscite più a ritrovarlo
[Musica]
per questo trucchetto prendete un
elastico è una graffetta in questo modo
andremo a creare un segnalibro che non
segna solo la pagina ma segna anche la
parola questo è utile anche se leggete
un libro ma magari non finite il
capitolo non finite la pagina ma vi
fermate a una parola specifica con la
graffetta potete cerchiare la parola
dove siete rimasti e chiudere il libro è
lasciare il vostro segnalibro anzi segna
parola nel vostro libro quinto
trucchetto ho deciso di cambiare
nuovamente la cover alla mia azienda a
me se volete potete togliere la cover
che avete messo prima oppure potete
semplicemente a pizzicarla sopra e ho
cambiato anche la ics al centro ed ecco
qua secondo me questa combinazione di
colori e fantastica per questo
trucchetto vi servono semplicemente dei
pennarelli vi consiglio il partire dal
colore più chiaro
prendete degli altri pennarelli
appoggiate la punta sopra è molto simile
a quello con l'evidenziatore ma non
creerà un tratto contro i colori ma
invece creerà una sfumatura di tutti i
colori che avete appoggiato sulla punta
del pennarello come potete vedere mano a
mano che utilizzate il pennarello escono
fuori tutti i colori potete creare delle
bellissime sfumature sia per colorare la
vostra agenda si o per scrivere magari
un messaggio multicolor
potete anche mischiare vari colori
diversi potete provare con tutte le
tonalità che volete io qua ho provato
con un po di verde un post celeste è un
po di rosa
sesto trucchetto questo trucchetto è
davvero divertentissimo e potete
utilizzarlo per fare uno scherzo ai
vostri compagni di classe
se vi capita che vi state addormentando
in classe
beh può capitare insomma magari alla
lezione un po noiosa o forse non avete
dormito molto la notte prima
[Musica]
con questo trucchetto potete fare una
foto i vostri occhi e stamparla oppure
potete ritagliare degli occhi da una
rivista un giornale dopodiché prendete
degli occhiali senza lenti ritagliate i
vostri occhi lo so sembra molto strano
detto così prendete appunto la forma
degli occhiali e ritagliate i vostri
occhi e attaccateli agli occhiali la
prossima volta che state per
addormentarvi il vostro compagno cerca
di svegliarvi indossate e gli occhiali
potrete quindi dormire tranquilli senza
che il vostro compagno se ne accorga
forze
[Musica]
vi voglio raf are vedere meglio le
nostre bellissime aziende hanno un sacco
di pagine per decorare e colorare dare
spazio alla vostra creatività oltre
appunto alle cover adesive che trovo
geniali perché così si può cambiare
stile al diario ogni volta che si vuole
poi esistono anche delle pagine molte
divertenti in cui potete scrivere le
vostre serie tv preferite e darli anche
un voto e anche tantissimi adesivi per
decorare la vostra agenda
spero che questo video vi sia piaciuto
lasciate un bel mi piace se volete
vedere altri trucchetti per la scuola e
fatemi sapere nei commenti qual è il
trucchetto che vi è piaciuto di più ora
vi lascio a 4 caselline su cui cliccare
per vedere i nostri altri video cliccate
su quella che preferite e buona visione
ciao
[Musica]